hey guys Pete here alright this is gonna
be my recap and review of mr. robot
season 3 episode 2 it was a really good
episode there will be spoilers obviously
if you haven't watched it so go watch
something else yeah it was a really
really good episode one of my favorites
I think it becomes a little bit clearer
now because I was a big fan of the
slow-moving character development of
season 2 I think that in retrospect now
we see that it strained us to not really
know what to expect and after a pretty
fast paced premiere this season I really
didn't know if we would get something
this high octane right after the fact
but we did and it worked really well
there was a lot of suspense a healthy
dose of mystery thrown in there and a
lot of stuff happened so it kicks off
with a callback I would say to the
season 1 montage where Elliot decides
that he's just gonna be normal after he
thinks he gets rid of mr. robot the
first time we have in excess playing in
the background new sensation as he
grooves into his new job at Ecore we
find out his whole plan is that he's
going to embrace them as a necessary
evil but make them better he's
transforming the real Elliot is
transforming into something new and he
believes that mr. robot is gone because
he hasn't felt him or seen him for weeks
of course we find out that's not the
case at all we found that out in the
premiere that mr. robots just as active
as ever and we get further confirmation
of that all throughout this episode we
also find out that Darlene is what
Elliot thinks is his trigger for mr.
robot and we'll get into that a little
bit later so if we try to break down
Elliot's plan here he's not becoming mr.
robot or he's not becoming the Elliot he
was he is trying to become the Elliot he
thinks he needs to be I really like that
self-examination moment when he says
that all of us talked about bringing
them down and saving the world or
changing the world
was perhaps just his dorm room
philosophizing I think it was effective
just for what it was that is Elliot
growing
but I think it's also kind of the show's
way of saying look you guys aren't
getting the big picture all the people
are being critical about Elliott he is a
guy who had good intentions but things
didn't turn out the way he planned he's
not so one-dimensional he makes sure to
tell us he's not selling out he's just
growing up and I think that that's a
real important notion for us to keep in
the back of our minds the Emoji stuff
was pretty funny I think it's a pretty
good satire on how we communicate these
days but long story short he seems to be
pretty effective in delaying everything
as far as stage 2 would be concerned but
we have to keep in mind that we know
more than he does he's not even sure of
stage 2 is still in the works he doesn't
know what Tyrells up to he doesn't know
what the dark Army's up to so he is
doing all this stuff but it is until
later in the episode that he gets a real
fear that stage 2 might still be going
ahead without him he does still try to
make things better from the inside he
gets several people arrested after
hacking them throughout Ecore but I
think this kind of points out to us that
you know he's trying to fix evil Corp by
rooting out these sort of systemic
issues that he comes across but he's not
doing that with himself he's avoiding
Darlene we find out later because he
thinks that might take care of mr. robot
but that's also pretty naive if you
think about it he's not really doing
much different than what he's done in
the past and we see that come out later
when we see the loneliness return he's
trying to do these sort of cosmetic
fixes or simple solutions for real
complex problems that are going on
inside of him and he ends up crying
again and going back to Christa I really
love that callback there to the
loneliness I think that's one of the
things that makes this character and
this series very relatable he's an
extreme case but that's something that
we all experienced at one time or
another and his obsession you know what
I mean he's very obsessed obviously so
much to the point that we find out that
he forgot it was his
Earth Day until he's sitting in front of
Christa so that's another window into
his frame of mind I believe but he does
sit with her and he talks to her
honestly and he tells her a little bit
more about the day that he was thrown
out the window but then realizes that he
never actually told her that his father
did that that that happened it's curious
I mean that kind of gets glossed over
because of the pace of the episode but
we haven't really seen Elliott forget
something like that in this context I
mean obviously he manages everything
that he distributes to Christa pretty
carefully he's very suspicious of the
whole situation so for him to think that
he had told her I think that's really
kind of something that's important
although I don't have a good explanation
of how that will play out but anyway as
we find out that him and his sister were
obsessed with home alone which is
interesting that they made a snowman
about Kevin McCallister and that comes
up later in the episode as well we do
get confirmation that Darlene is working
with the FBI we pretty much knew that I
mentioned that in all of my videos for
episode 1 she has immunity which is good
for her and she is trying to direct them
towards Tyrell but we also find out that
she didn't know the extent of Tyrells
involvement and that the FBI actually
knows a lot more than her as well so I
guess there's a lot of play of that here
you know who's really in control
Elliot thinks he's in control of the mr.
robot situation we know that's incorrect
Darlene thinks she knows what's going on
with things but the FBI is actually in
control so there's a lot of that sort of
stuff going on the big shock of the
episode of just like straight shock
value was clearly Joana's and her demise
which I didn't see coming I don't think
anybody else saw that coming as well she
looks like she is in total control when
she goes on the TV show we see their
plans playing out just as she wanted
she's got a sympathetic ear there with
the conspiracy theory crowd who are
behind her but on the way home after
saying that she still loves Tyrell the
boyfriend feels betrayed mr. Sutherlin
tries to
straighten him out but he ends up firing
some shots into the car and one of them
delivers a fatal wound to Joanna
it was really like I said it was a shock
it was sad I liked the character and a
love to hate kind of way and I'm sad to
see her go it's a bit surprising too I
mean she was setting her it seemed like
they were setting her up in season two
to be very influential throughout the
rest of the story but now she just sort
of has been reduced to a pawn in the
game and when we see the FBI agent Suzie
Dom in Santiago talking in there to
Dom's dismay they're using the baby
putting it in Child Protective Services
as a way to try to get Tyrell out of
hiding I think they definitely put the
period on the end of the sentence there
when they showed the autopsy they don't
really leave much chance for her to not
be dead usually when they extract your
skull cap and scoop your brain out of
your head you're probably not in a very
good chance of coming back in anyway the
crysta stuff and the Darlene stuff and
how it relates to mr. robot and the FBI
is very interesting because of what's
happened
Darlene gives them access to Elliot's
screen and we can pretty much guess that
he would be onto that if mr. robot
wasn't onto that and we find out later
that is the case I think it's safe to
say that Darlene is definitely
conflicted about doing what she's doing
she is on Elliot's side even though her
actions are calendar to what eff society
had done in the past and when all of
that stuff seems like wow that's really
a lot to jam into an episode there only
gets a whole Philip rice and White Rose
situation and I got to tell you I love
it
we knew the BD Wong who plays White Rose
had been promoted to a series regular in
the off season I don't think anybody was
disappointed to hear that but man this
is a good character the showdown after
price his speech was just perfect and I
really liked this particular line that
he dropped when he says don't mistake my
generosity for generosity great line
the delivery was perfect it was really
good all the way around for a brief
overview of what's happening here
price is trying to capitalize on the
five nine hack by making a coin the new
world currency there in Turkey for the
g20 summit but we learned that China is
not on board that they're gonna back
Bitcoin this obviously undermines all of
crisis plan so he's not happy about it
we know from season two that they are
trying to do something where China
annexes the Congo initially we thought
that was for rare materials and that
could be part of the case obviously but
from now on season three were a little
bit more clear that White Rose wants to
move the particle collider operation
from New Jersey to the mines that are
there in the Congo price tries to dangle
this in front of him the fact that he
worked on getting the UN to sign off on
it but he's quickly countered by White
Rose who says that he basically has
control of Angela so that was really
good I'm really excited to see how that
plays out I've always liked the Phillip
price character even though he's a total
scumbag and there's just some kind of
voyeuristic thing that's really
satisfying to watch these two very
powerful characters so they're gonna be
butting heads until something happens
and we find out that White Rose is
fairly vindictive as well I mean when we
think of the character as being
calculated gold hoary into not really
petty I wouldn't say I mean they're the
obsession with time everything else but
we find out that stage two will go
through and flight Rose has anything to
do with it whether they get the Congo or
not at this point he just wants to
deliver a slap to the hand of Phillip
price so super interesting there so the
FBI has access Elliott sends off a file
to somebody named Eugene Bell Ford the
new character Dom's new partner doesn't
find anything in the file but of course
that's what Elliott wanted to have
happen that's the only thing that went
out of his computer I think it's
interesting though that it happened at
night
and this could actually be mr. robot
operating not Elliot himself either way
sir is the security camera without any
narration I might add from Elliot we see
Elliot arrived at the safe house as he
was able to get the IP address or
something and find their location as
Dom's looking at him it's another
callback to this idea of control they
thought that they had just made a big
advance in being able to see what Elliot
was up to and now Elliot's standing in
their lair and the big question for us
as viewers is is it Elliot or is it mr.
robot I really really enjoyed the
conversation between Krista and mr.
robot come to think of that I mean it's
the same kind of deal mr. robot is
someone that we think has total control
over what he's doing but we see a bit of
a different side of him here I mean of
course he still has the same personality
that differs wildly from Elliot but he
has real concern about Krista and her
involvement with Elliot's life so I
think overall I mean this was a great
great episode totally shocked by Johanna
it had some light moments the Elliot
pitching the ideas to his bosses and
doing the whole new routine new
sensation playing in the background was
fun wondering how things are gonna turn
out between whiterose and Phillip price
is definitely mysterious and exciting I
feel sad for Darlie she is definitely
between a rock and a hard place here
there was some really emotional moments
with her and Elliot as brother and
sister so yeah it had a little bit of
everything and I really enjoyed it so
what I'll do next is I will do a trailer
breakdown looking at the scenes from the
next episode and then I'll go back
through and look at all of these Easter
eggs just like I did in episode 1 there
was definitely some that stood out on
the first watch that I want to look into
closer so I'm going to edit this video
get it out and then I'll move on to
those other projects definitely tell me
in the comments what you think I mean
this season is
definitely on the right track as much as
I loved season 2 I have no problems with
what they're doing right now and I can't
wait to see what happens next please
like the video if you enjoyed it make
sure you subscribe to my channel I'm
doing videos at least 3 videos a week
per episode it looks like so subscribe
now and hit notification so you'll know
when the next one comes out follow me on
Twitter and Instagram and Facebook
whichever one you like I try to be as
active as possible and that's the best
way to interact with me and give a
thought of checking out my patreon I
could use your support and I would love
to have your input over there on the
future of the channel that's it for now
thanks for watching guys I'll talk to
you soon